chanting slogans and pounding drums
striking hotel workers marched in
downtown Los Angeles on the 4th of July
holiday
15 000 housekeepers Bell hops
dishwashers and other workers are
demanding a five dollar an hour
immediate pay increase and more over the
next several years
housekeeper Anna Pinero helps her
daughter Jennifer Flores also a hotel
worker care for Flores six-year-old son
also gas groceries take
School having
children we've I've been involved with
her since I was in high school so back
then she was also fighting to finish
raising me now I'm doing the same thing
to help her and my child
a recent study showed that renting a
basic one-bedroom apartment in La
requires an annual income of more than
sixty thousand dollars a hotel
housekeeper's average wage is about
forty thousand dollars a year I have
three kids and I have to support it
depend on me and my patient and as you
know in La everything every year is
getting higher and higher the cost of
living is really expensive
hotels have remained open but are short
staffed some guests at the luxury JW
Marriott Hotel struggled to carry their
own luggage a statement from the hotel
companies accused the hotel workers
union of not bargaining in good faith
the hotel workers
and Hollywood actors are in the last
stages of their negotiations with
Studios and may also walk off the job
the major delivery company UPS is also
gearing up for a nationwide strike as
talks with its Workers Union appear to
have broken down I think what that shows
is the reality
[Music]
making a lot of money but yet their
workers are struggling and so if that
says anything that we're in a collective
struggle all of us together here in the
states
it's the beginning of what could be a
long hot labor summer in California and
across the U.S Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera
Los Angeles
[Music]